[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
béroud théâtre de violences aujourd'hui
des milliers de libanais en colère sont
mobilisés dans le centre-ville de la
capitale des affrontements ont eu lieu
entre forces de l'ordre et manifestants
selon la croix rouge libanaise lloris 55
blessés un policier a été tué plusieurs
ministères ont été pris d'assaut par les
protestataires
quatre jours après le drame le premier
ministre hassan diab annonce qu'il va
proposer des élections anticipées après
l'explosion meurtrière le coronavirus
frappe de plein fouet l amérique du sud
et les caraïbes
ces régions comptabilise le plus grand
nombre de décès dus au virus au monde
on y déplore plus de deux cent mille
morts à titre d'exemple le brésil et
fondement frappé par la pandémie avec 3
millions de malades et près de cent
mille morts en absence de touristes le
pays craint de voir son économie
s'effondrer
[Musique]
la crainte d'une catastrophe écologique
d'envergure ne cesse d'augmenter à l'île
maurice la france portent secours aux
autorités mauriciennes après le naufrage
du wac à chiots elle des moyens
matériels et humains ont été déployés
depuis la réunion pour aider à contenir
la pollution maritime
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur rt
france il est 20 heures
la colère gronde dans les rues de
beyrouth en ce moment même des milliers
de libanais manifeste à des
affrontements ont lieu entre les forces
de l'ordre et les manifestants est la
capitale est le théâtre de violences
après de 55 blessés selon la croix-rouge
libanaise et un policier a été tué
le ministre de l'économie et des
affaires étrangères ont été pris
d'assaut ainsi que le qg de
l'association à des banques
quatre jours après la double explosion
qui a fait au moins 158 morts et 6000
blessés
le premier ministre hassan diab annonce
qu'il va proposer des élections
anticipées après cette explosion ait les
protestataires sont sur la place des
martyrs une place devenue l'emblème de
la révolution et quelques jours après le
drame à beyrouth l'opposition jette
l'épongé
samy gemayel chef du parti kataëb les
phalanges libanaises a démissionné
aujourd'hui deux autres députés du parti
chrétien et une députée indépendante
également je cite l'opposition de
l'intérieur n'est plus efficace
reconnaît l'une des démissionnaires
une décision qui arrive également à la
suite du décès du secrétaire général du
parti nizar najarian mort lors de la
double explosion
après emmanuel macron le président du
conseil européen charles michel est
arrivé à beyrouth une visio conférence
des donateurs en soutien au liban aura
lieu ce dimanche elle sera co organisée
par l'onu à la france
il s'agira de faire part de la
solidarité des européens ce pays dont la
capitale a été dévastée par les
explosions meurtrières ce mardi charles
michel a notamment rencontré le
président du parlement libanais il s'est
ensuite entretenu avec le président
michel round et le premier ministre
hassan diab nous avons aussi eu
l'occasion dont cet entretien
d'ouvrir le dialogue sera question des
réformes sont indispensables pour
renforcer la gouvernance pour faire en
sorte que l'on puisse réformer le
système financier que l'on puisse faire
reculer la corruption prendre des
actions très résolue contre la
corruption font partie des engagements à
nos yeux qui sont importants dans le
cadre d'un dialogue avec l'union
européenne et plus généralement avec des
sommités internationales
la commission européenne a déjà
coordonné l'envoi de 300 sauveteurs à
beyrouth et débloqué 33 millions d'euros
pour les premiers besoins d'urgence
notamment de l'aide médicale
plus de détails en images
[Musique]
nous vous invitons donc à intensifier le
soutien que vous apportez au liban non
seulement pour répondre aux besoins
immédiats mais également en vue de la
reconstruction à plus long terme du pays
dans un souci d'efficacité et de
rapidité de la mise en oeuvre
nous sommes disposés à assurer la
synergie entre l'assistance que vous
fournirez au liban et celle que l'union
européenne dans son ensemble lui
apportera au moyen d'un mécanisme de
coordination que les institutions de
l'union européenne mettront en place
[Musique]
nous ne devons pas oublier le
partenariat solides qui existent entre
l'union européenne et le liban pays
d'importance stratégique qui accueille
le plus grand nombre de réfugiés par
habitant nous nous sommes engagés en
faveur de la stabilité du pays en
apportant une assistance économique en
fournissant un soutien aux réfugiés
syriens
et récemment en riposte à la pandémie de
covile 19 en mettant en place des
programmes visant à renforcer le système
de santé et à s'attaquer aux
conséquences socio-économiques de la
pandémie
m
[Applaudissements]
les institutions européennes insiste sur
la nécessité d'entreprendre les réformes
qui sont attendus par la population
il faudra assurer que les fonds qui
seront mises à disposition soit géré de
la manière la plus efficace possible
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec hyman mana directeur exécutif de la
fondation samir kassir alemana merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
votre réaction d'abord à ces images ces
scènes de violence dans les rues de
beyrouth vous étiez à cette
manifestation
racontez nous un petit peu comment
comment s'est déroulé ce rassemblement
c'était une manifestation très
importante
l'une des plus grandes depuis le
déclenchement des manifestations le 17
octobre 2019
des groupes très divers étaient présents
sur place également avec des jeunes qui
ont tenté de s'approcher de l'enceinte
du parlement qui est bloquée par les
forces de l'ordre après 200 mètres du
parlement des deux côtés ouest est et
était 17 heures il ya eu des
échauffourées des tentatives de dépasser
les obstacles qui était qui étaient
mises en place et les forces de l'ordre
ont répliqué avec une violence
incroyable en termes de dông de
lacrymogènes qui ont été déversées de
manière assez indiscriminée dès 17h30 ce
qui a plus que ce qui était peut-être
une stratégie pour empêcher un
rassemblement encore plus important ça
montre à quel point les autorités sont
fébriles
il ya eu un peu plus de 55 blessés il ya
eu un policier tué il y avait plusieurs
ministères qui ont été pris d'assaut par
les manifestants
on a l'impression d'un sentiment que les
libanais n'ont presque plus rien à
perdre
selon vous jusqu'où sont ils capables
d'aller c'est une question qu'il faudra
poser aux autorités politiques qui ont
démontré ces quatre derniers jours après
le drame incroyable qui a frappé notre
ville
leur incapacité totale à assurer le
minimum de ce qui est demandé d'une
autorité responsable
ils se sont renvoyés la balle se sont
accusés les uns les autres que
d'être responsable de ce qui s'est passé
ce que nous savons en tant que libanais
c'est que toutes les autorités étaient
au courant du stockage de 2007 150
tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium juste même
le 20 juillet dernier le premier
ministre le président de la république
la ministre de la justice le ministre
des transports étaient tous mis au
courant par les services de sécurité de
saint-georges et et rien n'a été fait et
on sait que rien n'a été fait depuis
2013 depuis 2014
ces autorités là y compris le président
de la république clame qu'il n'a pas par
exemple les prérogatives
une autre personne qu'il n'était pas
informé une troisième personne qu'elle
n'était pas nécessairement au courant
ça montre à quel point ces autorités
sont incapables de gérer quoi que ce
soit et imaginez leur incapacité à gérer
un événement de cette ampleur
face à cela les libanais n'ont peuvent
plus aujourd'hui près de 300 me libanais
ne peuvent pas dormir chez eux il y a
aujourd'hui une incapacité totale de
réparer les dégâts étant donné la crise
économique et l'effondrement de la livre
libanaise
même si on pouvait réparer même si on
avait les moyens
techniquement il est impossible
d'importer vu la destruction du port
face à cela les autorités ne font
absolument rien aucune responsabilité
politique aucune responsabilité pénale
et on a vraiment l'impression qu'elle
vole tergiverser afin de revenir à la
normale comme d'habitude parce qu'au
liban depuis 30 ans plein de crimes ont
été commis
même depuis la guerre en 75 plein de
crimes ont été commis
rien n'a été fait pour qu'un responsable
comme ça et ma nana justement vous
parlez du gouvernement hassan diab le
premier ministre libanais a annoncé
qu'il y aurait des élections anticipées
est ce que cela suffira à calmer la
colère du peuple qui est déterminé
depuis des mois on sait samedi on a raté
une excellente occasion soit de
démissionner soit de se taire parce
qu'il a joué avec les mots il n'a pas
annoncé des élections anticipées
il a dit qu'il proposera lundi au
gouvernement au conseil des ministres
d'organiser des élections anticipées de
proposer un projet de loi qui serait
envoyé au parlement pour que le
parlement accepte de réduire son mandat
de raccourcir son manga est donc d'aller
vers des élections anticipées
c'est donc rentrer dans un jeu politique
ridicule d'une lenteur qu'on connaît au
liban ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'on ce qu'on se perd dans des méandres
législatif administratif et
bureaucratique
alors qu'on lui demande une seule chose
c'est pour une fois de sa vie de se
comporter en responsable c'est un homme
qui a su au moins le 20 juillet dernier
même avant que il y avait au port ce
stockage de manière très dangereuse et
il n'a absolument rien fait il a dit je
n'étais pas conscient je m'occupais
d'autres dossiers
je me permets de vous interrompre car on
est un petit peu pris par le temps
pourquoi selon vous michel ans le
président libanais refuse l'idée d'une
enquête internationale le président
michel hug ne veut pas connaître la
vérité et ne veut pas que le peuple
libanais connaissent la vérité 1 sur ce
qu'il savait lui même depuis son
accession à la présidence
quant à ce port il ne veut pas qu'on
sache ce qui se trame au port de manière
légale et illégale aussi concernant les
différentes parties libanaises
il ne veut pas que les personnes qui le
protège qui sont corrompus soient
exposées et il protège de ce fait là
toute la classe politique même les gens
qui officiellement sont six opposants
certains certains libanais demande à
être sous mandat français pendant dix
ans c'est une décision qui peut sembler
surprenante comment est-ce que les
libanais en sont arrivés là
je pense que c'était une forte de
d'appel qui était beaucoup plus
émotionnel que réelle
aucun parti politique aucune composante
même de la révolution ne pense à cela
aujourd'hui les libanais envoie en
disant cela un signe de dégoût et de
dédain et de refus total à l'égard de
cette classe politique il accepterait
presque tout mandat tout gouvernant sauf
celle de ces partis qui depuis 75 et
surtout depuis 30 ans ont conduit le
pays à sa misère et surtout à la mort de
centaines de personnes
selon vous quelle est la solution pour
avoir une perspective d'avenir à tous
ces jeunes libanais qui veulent pouvoir
vivre paisible
et qui veulent pouvoir grandir dans leur
pays les solutions sont à court terme et
à long terme à court terme rapidement
organisés de manière très efficace
l'aide internationale hors des
structures de l'état libanais en
organisant un certain parrainage
international de cette aide
en allant directement à la population à
travers des ong que tous les bailleurs
de fonds connaissent et respectent
deuxièmement une enquête internationale
et troisième mois un appui libanais et
internationales pour un gouvernement
réellement indépendant d'experts qui va
mettre toute la lumière sur ce qui s'est
passé
prendre des mesures contre la corruption
et permettre le retour de l'aide
internationale au liban ce n'est que
lorsque l'aide internationale de court
terme et l'aide économique reviendra
qu'on pourra remettre en oeuvre remettre
sur place notre vie économique et
rétablir une forme de normalité mais
avec cette classe politique
c'est complètement impossible c'est même
naïf de prétendre croire et c'est ce que
je dirai à charles michel c'est ce que
j'ai personnellement dit à jean yves le
drian et ce qui a été dit à emmanuel
macron avec cette classe politique ce
serait naïf d'attendre quoi que ce soit
qui aille dans un sens des réformes et
de la lutte contre la corruption à émana
merci beaucoup pour cet éclairage
rappelle que vous êtes directeur
exécutif de la fondation samir kassir
merci à vous l épidémie de covile 19 qui
continuait sa progression dans le monde
hier l amérique latine et les caraïbes
sont devenus la région du globe la plus
endeuillée avec que de deux cent mille
morts le brésil reste le pays le plus
touché avec 3 millions de malades et
près de cent mille morts et qui dit
crise sanitaire dit crise économique
le pays souffre et les touristes se font
rares reportage d'augusta lunardi avec
walid bennani
des images rares inédites ont visité
chaque année par des millions de
touristes venant des quatre coins du
monde le corcovado l'un des principaux
symboles de rio dé janeiro est
complètement vide depuis cinq mois à
cause de la pandémie de kovy 19 le site
touristique est fermé pour la première
fois en 88 ans le père omar raposo le
responsable du sanctuaire au de 38
mètres a été obligé d'organiser ces
messes en dehors de la chapelle du
christ rédempteur
depuis l'arrivée du virus au brésil il
s'inquiète pour l'avenir du tourisme à
rio dé janeiro un secteur qui apporte
chaque année plus de 5 milliards de
dollars à la ville merveilleuse
la pandémie a touché fortement le
tourisme à rio et sur toute la planète
d'ailleurs le christ est toujours là
mais tout le secteur touristique autour
de lui a beaucoup souffert
notre économie a besoin des touristes
tandis vont être riches entrées de
touristes
sans eux la ville est à l'arrêt c'est
pour ça que nous avons besoin de
retourner à la normale mais ce n'est pas
encore le moment elle les guides
touristiques comme tous les travailleurs
non déclarés au brésil font partie des
principales victimes des conséquences de
la pandémie
ces jours là une vingtaine d'entre eux
se sont réunis dans l'un des marchés les
plus populaire de rio pour demander
l'application d'un projet de loi
proposant une aide d'urgence aux guides
touristiques
il n'y a plus de touristes donc on n'a
plus de revenus on nous dit qu'il faut
qu'on change de métier mais comment je
vais changer de métier en pleine
épidémie quand tout est fermé il n'y a
pas de travail
ennahda guide à rio dé janeiro depuis 15
ans a elle aussi perdu ses revenus du
jour au lendemain comme ses collègues et
naïda a été obligé de se réinventer
pas toujours facile dans un contexte de
crise sanitaire et économique pour
continuer à payer ses factures à la
décidé de vendre des gâteaux et des
biscuits à domicile et dans les marchés
je suis resté sans travail pendant
quatre mois nous les guides
on a été les premiers touchés et on n'a
aucune perspective de changement
le gouvernement nous a tourné le dos
c'est tellement triste
le tourisme de luxe n'a pas été plus
épargnée par la pandémie à rio dé
janeiro 57 hôtels ont fermé leurs portes
et situé sur la plage d'ipanema
le célèbre hôtel face à no 1 des plus
chics de la ville a été obligé d'annuler
toutes les réservations pendant plus de
trois mois
avec l'assouplissement des règles de
confinement l'établissement a pu rouvrir
ses portes tout en limitant sa capacité
d'occupation de 50% et en respectant une
série de précautions sanitaires
on a mis toutes nos serviettes dans des
sacs plastiques
il n'y a plus fait pour le petit
déjeuner quand nous avons vu que 700 des
noues touché le tourisme cela nous a
fait peur mais nous les habitants de rio
nous sommes toujours optimistes richter
depuis l'arrivée du coc vite 19 au
brésil le secteur du tourisme a déjà
accumulé des pertes de plus de 17
milliards de dollars
on estime qu'au moins trois cent mille
personnes auraient perdu leur emploi
dans le secteur alors que la menace
d'une deuxième vague plane au dessus du
monde entier certains émettent des
doutes sur l'existence même du
coronavirus on les appelle les coronale
sceptiques ils manifestent leur colère
depuis quelques jours face au
renforcement des mesures sanitaires
notamment le port du masque alors qui
sont ils et pourquoi doute il
explications en images
[Musique]
pour
non
[Musique]
en france la situation sanitaire se
dégrade en l'espace de 24 heures le pays
a recensé plus de 2000 nouvelles
contaminations au corona virus une nette
accélération par rapport à la veille où
il était question de 1600 cas la
direction générale de la santé confirme
une circulation plus active du virus en
particulier chez les jeunes
l ile de france la région paca les hôtes
france et la guyane sont les régions les
plus touchées
conséquence plusieurs grandes et ont
décidé de rendre le port du masque
obligatoire à l'extérieur et pour en
parler avec nous en direct michel
maffesoli sociologue et professeur
émérite de sociologie à la sorbonne pour
parler de ce phénomène grandissant ces
dernières semaines l agacement du port
du masque
michel maffesoli bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
alors on l'a vu les pétitions se
multiplient les groupes facebook sont
créées sous fond de théories du complot
comment est-ce que vous expliquer ce
phénomène
d'abord il faut opérer comme ça une
peste d'incohérences dans la le fait
qu'il faille ou pas porter le masque et
on a vu que pendant deux mois les
autorités elles mêmes n'étaient pas très
au clair sur ce qu'il en était bon et
puis y'a c'est en effet ce problème de
la relativisation de la pandémie quand
il faudrait moi je suis pas compétent en
la matière m'empêche quand on regarde un
peu les chiffres de par le monde
eh bien on se rend bien compte que à
côté des schistes en mille morts ce
qu'on vit il ya chaque année trois
millions de morts pour tel type de
cancer ou tel type d'infections
pulmonaires ou autres malaria voyez donc
plus comme je peu à peu ça commence à m
chez les gens même une certaine tout sur
la pandémie
alors c'est dans cette ville dans cette
mise en perspective que le fait qu'il
faille porter le masque par tous n'est
pas quelque chose de fichiers facilement
acceptable et pour compléter ce que aux
images viennent de dire c'est pas
uniquement les chefs d'état que vous
avez cités qui relativise le port du
masque ces nombres de moi j'ai des
collègues
rené descartes professeur de médecine
qui lie publiquement montré que ce qu'il
en était déjà là c'était une chaire est
encore une fois une manière d'une
stratégie de la peur ou la est la
réponse à cette stratégie
alors bien sûr les réseaux sociaux qui
vont se réveiller et puis regardez
comment régulièrement chaque au choix ou
peut-être pas chaque soir il ya des
grands rassemblements festifs les jeunes
canadiens qui voulait à la fois du
confinement de cet éloignement
en effet le fait que avec cette
distanciation social il n'y a plus ce
qui est le propre même de la société de
rentrer en contact avec l'autre est
patente et voilà donc il doit être
nuancé la des endroits bien sûr le
masque héros ne peut plus nécessaire les
hôpitaux sont une des manifestations
mais à côté de cela il ya le refus de
cette stratégie de la peur
ok machiavel et qui dit les bêlements
heures devient le maître de l'horreur
alors comment est ce qu'on fait
justement jong et vous parlez de cette
stratégie de la peur comment est-ce
qu'on peut jongler entre responsabilité
collective et ne pas sombrer dans la
paranoïa
d'abord soyons clairs il y avait fait
moi je suis parce que c'est pas le mot
paranoïa qui me kill me viendrait à
l'expliquer le mot clic aux ou le
mouiller ferry en quelque sorte
alors ben je viens de vous dire comment
je vous laisse à dire il ya des lieux
manifestement où c'est nécessaire les
lieux de soins par exemple en sont des
belles expressions c'est pas certain
qu'il faille à partir de l'étendre dans
ce qui t'a fait le lieu que les clauses
et à dire grands magasins et maintenant
apparemment également sur les marchés où
elle a donc je voyais et mon hypothèse
c'est qu'il va y avoir à l'automne toute
une série de soulèvements contre
l'oligarchie en général et le refus du
masque actuellement est peut être le
prémice de cela en particulier chez les
jeunes générations
alors je ne sais pas si fausse 11
janvier mais en tout cas il faut
constater mon métier c'est de constater
un certain nombre de choses de repérer
ce qui est en train de se passer et on
voit bien quelle quantité de gens qui
n'ont pas envie de se plier au port du
masque
michel maffesoli
merci pour cet éclairage on rappelle que
vous êtes sociologue et professeur
émérite de sociologie à la sorbonne est
la france qui porte secours à l'île
maurice après le naufrage du wac à chaud
ce samedi des équipements et des
spécialistes ont été envoyés de la
réunion pour aider à contenir la
pollution maritime
le vraquier échoué sur un récif
mauricien depuis le 25 juillet a laissé
s'échapper et des nappes d'hydrocarbures
faisant une catastrophe écologique eu
envie de mourir la crainte d'une
catastrophe écologique d'envergure ne
cesse d'augmenter à l'île maurice depuis
plus de deux semaines le wac à chiots et
échoué sur la côte sud-est de cette
terre située dans l'océan indien
le vraquier qui appartient à un armateur
japonais mais battant pavillon panaméen
voyager à vie tout en transportant 200
tonnes de diesel et 3800 tonnes d'huile
lourde des hydrocarbures très polluants
qui ont déjà commencé à s'échapper du
navire face à la menace d'une marée
noire les autorités mauriciennes ont
demandé jeudi le soutien de la france
un appel à l'aide entendu par paris
lorsque la biodiversité est en péril
il y a urgence d'agir la france est là
aux côtés du peuple mauricien
vous pouvez compter sur notre soutien
cher praveen jobs note
nous déployons dès à présent des équipes
et du matériel depuis la réunion ce
samedi la france a donc commencé à
livrer son aide en équipements et en
personnel depuis l'île voisine de la
réunion un avion tactique de transport
militaire ainsi qu'un navire de la
marine nationale achemine une dizaine
d'experts et plus de 6 tonnes de
matériel dont des barrages côtiers et du
matériel de pompage
c'est la première fois que nous sommes
confrontés à une catastrophe pareille et
nous ne sommes pas suffisamment équipé
pour traiter ce problème
inquiète d'une aggravation de la
situation les autorités mauriciennes ont
aussi demandé le soutien de l'afrique du
sud est pour ça qu on annonce
spécialiste des affaires maritimes les
mauriciens déploie tous les moyens pour
minimiser les risques de propagation des
hydrocarbures écouteurs on prévoit des
gens en un anticyclone lendemain avec
des formules où le risque que le bateau
ce cas sont deux et là le risque est
très élevé
on essaye ici à maurice tout le monde se
met la main à la pâte
on met tout ce qui est dans la mesure du
possible nous les mauriciens on s'aime
on essaye d'arrêter de d'arrêter cette
propagation du nul qui inédit cap mais
on dit c'est de minimiser les risques et
c'est la fin ce journal merci de l'avoir
suivi prochaine édition dans 30 minutes
rester avec ta sur arte france
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coupe
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
qu'est ce que vous répondez à tous ceux
qui disent aujourd'hui que l'effort
militaire ne correspond plus à nos
besoins
les crises géostratégique c'est comme
les crises sanitaires c'est pas au
moment où on est dedans qu'il faut s'en
priver